back in 1971 just at the beginning of
when structures of proteins were being
determined it was quite a task to be
able to distribute those data if you
wanted to the protein databank
began as a grassroots effort on the part
of many scientists to figure out a way
to archive protein structures in 1998
the management of the protein databank
turned to the research collaboratory for
structural bioinformatics rcsb and we
began to manage those data the PDB had
its origins with just seven x-ray
structures of proteins it's now nearly a
hundred thousand entries in the archive
more than 40 years later there's
literally a million downloads or entries
in the archives on a daily basis the
information can be used by anyone for
any purpose without any restrictions our
CSV PDB provides the users the ability
to visualize molecules to do all kinds
of analysis and comparison of these
structures for the experts this provides
an opportunity to look at their protein
of interest and compare it to other
relatives so the PDB is a great resource
I mean it's the world's only single
resource for protein structures and it's
a wonderful resource because the whole
community uses it my lab focuses on RNA
viruses we submit them to the PDB and
then it's available to the community so
that other crystallographers can see how
we've modeled things in 2003 we formed a
consortium called the worldwide PDB in
which we brought in the people from
Europe and Asia so that we would all
work together to keep a single archive
ww PDB is a consortium of four data
centers in insurance that we have
uniform archive and that the annotation
practices are uniform as well for
several years we've been developing a
new
come on the position annotation tool
that would be uniform for all the
centers but these four centers actually
compete on how to represent the data on
the data out step the RCS P we have
decided Rutgers and we have a site at
the University of California in San
Diego
at Rutgers our primary responsibility is
to curate the data so we have people
annotators who review the data that
comes in and then they communicate with
the depositors of the data to be sure
that everything is as well represented
as possible the declaration is a fairly
complicated task it could be data
standardization like we standardized
atomic nomenclature data validation we
validate model against experimental data
and importantly we cross-reference the
data to other databases such as uniprot
or drug drug Bank this is all done to
have high quality highly standardized
validated data that could be used by
scientists and non-scientists worldwide
molecules to some people seem to be very
abstract and in our view they're very
concrete you can hold a model of a
molecule in your hand and so one very
important aspect of what we do is that
we work with students and educators in
order to have them understand molecules
teaching resources that they have
they're really really fantastic the
information that's available is for
teaching it's wonderful
they have little models and really
really helpful especially at the
undergraduate level where you're trying
to get students interested in
understanding structural biology one of
the most popular resources of the rcsb
PDB is the molecule of the month this is
an article that is written by David
Goodsell so that anybody high school
students and anybody can read it and
understand what this molecule looks like
how it interacts and does whatever it is
supposed to do we also have various
educational resources and tutorials and
lesson plans for teachers and students
protein databank has gathered up all
these educational resources into a
separate section which we call the pdb
101 which presents a less complicated
view of the protein databank so that
they're not overwhelmed by the large
amount of data and complexity that is
archived about three-quarters of our
users are not the individuals who are
depositing the data into the archive
they're people who are simply using that
information for either teaching or or
research purposes now our focus while
remaining true to our depositors is
shifting toward
the user base - information about the
protein databank available to the
students as they begin to explore
biology one of the goals that we are
striving towards is to present a
structural view of biology we want the
users to come to the PDB and understand
a biological process a disease process a
treatment program or any other aspect of
biology from a molecular structural
perspective the great wish I think would
be to be able to predict protein
structure by simply looking at the
sequence that's how this all began many
many years ago that's very important
intellectually as well as medical